this is very exciting guys and you might
not have heard of these
a mask and i'm sure that sounds very
like okay great yeah face mask what you
couldn't think of a tenth essential
this is so essential right now this is
the most essential
aside from nurses and carers and
delivery people and all the people that
are working on the front lines but this
is what we can do what's up gq i'm ruby
rose and these
are my essentials
[Music]
this is one of my essentials because
it's
a i don't know what it's called i'm a
big fan clearly
remarkable and as you can see oh i don't
know how much you can see actually but
it's pretty dented and pretty
bruised and it's traveled with me for a
long time but this
is what i read my scripts on so i prefer
to be paperless the environment
so forth but also i can't just use my
laptop or just use an ipad because
a the color and my eyes get really tight
after a while and b
there's your emails pop up your text
messages pop up all these things and you
get distracted and then you're not
reading the script but you can write on
script so if i receive a script and
download it to here i can write my notes
on the side of it and then send it back
to a director or a producer or you know
whatever
[Music]
what is this you might ask it's a yoga
mat yes for many years
my nier's resolution was to do yoga and
for many years i did not do yoga one of
the good things that have come
out of this tragic and sad time is that
i finally did yoga
and and a lot of other things to do with
self-care and and
exercise but i brought this mad in
because hey i'm quite proud that i do
yoga and pilates now and stretching
and also it's uh jaron street so it's an
australian
brand that sent me this in australia
there's a lot of
people that steal aboriginal designs
their art their
culture and they use a lot of their
artwork without permission
so this is aboriginal art done by
aboriginal people and they support other
indigenous brands as well so for me i
was like
this is really cool it's super
comfortable it looks awesome no it's
like samurai
sword in here what's happening and it's
also essential because when i stop
doing yoga or pilates my dogs decide
that this is what they're gonna nap on
for the whole day
look at this i could just get on the
table right now and do pilates
which i would have never done for the
last 30 years of my life so yeah it's my
essential because it was one of those
things that during this time
the final things to do we're trying to
work out how to stay busy mental health
physical health good food and yoga and
pilates
and stretching and things like that is a
really good way to meditate actually i
meditate on this as well
so they're all the good things
essentials boxing gloves also that this
doubles because it's also tie-dye
and one of the things i got really into
during foreign team was tie-dying
everything so when that's no longer cool
i'm in trouble because my i've
died everything i started boxing again
recently so for the first part of
quarantine
i gave myself this thing where i'm like
i've been exercising and training really
hard for 15 years i deserve to do
nothing and eat whatever i like
and i did that i still don't fit into
any of my jeans and i'm okay with that
but the one thing i recited up again
recently was boxing and i actually
competed
i was an amateur boxer for a couple of
years and i competed and one i'm
undefeated
because i was only two fights and my mum
made me stop but it is one of those
things where
i like to do the exercises that are good
for the soul and the spirit you know
pilates yoga meditation all of those
sorts of things but i also need to be
like cardio like i need to get
energy out and i think it's important to
when you get frustrated to have an
avenue
and boxing is a really good one for that
so when i'm kind of feeling
a bit foggy and i'm not feeling like i
have a purpose or direction or
you know that i can't do something
boxing is a great way to just go and
get all that out and get exercise at the
same time
three times a week and then i just did a
film with morgan freeman and i didn't
work out
for three weeks and then i went boxing
again and i lost all of that in three
weeks i'm
so mad but yeah i go three times a week
and i would go more but
i go to this place called glove works
and it's no joke they're really tough
this is a drink that i love i'm also an
investor in it so you know
just just keeping it real but i
basically harassed these guys because i
was spending so much money on this drink
getting one every day and trying all the
flavors that for a year i was hassling
them to be like come on like can i
invest in the company can we work
together i'm obsessed
what rev will do is they keep everything
so it can be sustainable and they
just go to the sauce so you get the best
ingredients this one is cold brew
coffee rishi so a lot of these have
chinese medicine herbs mushrooms
roots ashwagandha chaga they're all
really good for you and
coffee can make me feel like a bit
anxious if i have too much
whereas mushroom coffee never does can't
live without it
love it try it someday i don't know i'm
not trying to do an ad i just literally
can't live without it
this is trough this has changed my life
and mind you i've been practicing
to be less attached to things really
attached to this it's a truffle hot
sauce which
to me when i heard about it sounded like
the worst idea that anyone could come up
with
who wants a truffle hot sauce like
truffle on its own
is the flavor right i was wrong boy was
i wrong
i add this to everything literally
everything savory sweet
there's another one that's like white
truffle this one's black truffle
i give it to all my friends and people
are like really
happy birthday you got me hot sauce just
you wait
i go through a bottle this size every
three weeks maybe every two weeks
i can't think i'm so obsessed with hot
sauce this is weird and that it's one of
my essentials
anyway sorry about that
we're not really strangers this game is
unbelievable
it's such a fast track way to get to
know someone that you don't know
you get to find out really interesting
things about the other person in a way
that
feels so organic whereas if you're just
talking to someone at dinner or you're
on a date or you're hanging out for the
first time with a new friend
you can't just ask them these questions
like what did you really think about me
when you first met me
when you play the game it puts it in a
context that isn't weird
and i've not only like become really
close to people because of this game
i've also become closer to like my best
friends things that i didn't know about
them or they didn't know about me
i love anything that allows people to
feel more comfortable connecting
we misunderstand people and games like
this not only is it super fun
but you do you get a better
understanding of people and i love
connecting and i
have realized even more so during
quarantine i do need human connection i
do need my friends i do need to check in
on my family more
and now that i've done that that's one
part of quarantine that i won't stop
when we
go to the new normal whatever's gonna
happen there better you get people drunk
too because
they get more honest but you don't get
drunk and then you get to remember it
all
this oh it's on i'm gonna take it off
because it's on a rude finger
that's literally about my finger up this
is an aura ring and it's a sleep ring a
friend of mine convinced me to get this
i thought she was nuts i didn't really
get the idea it's amazing so it records
everything to your sleep pattern when
you go to sleep how long you sleep for
the quality of your sleep
all the things i know i'm talking about
sleep a lot but that's a really
important part of our health i totally
ditched sleep for the last
10 years because you know schedules and
traveling
sleep has always been a little difficult
for me and i
know that when i monitor it and i really
recognize what's happening okay i went
to bed at this time
and i only got this much good sleep was
it really worth it to watch grey's
anatomy
for the 20th time to lose this amount of
sleep so this thing
i i just i'm obsessed with it and i
think that if anyone has sleep problems
or
wants to know more about their sleep
then this is a great thing to get
crystals yes i'm one it's so la isn't it
but i swear i did this when i was in
australia so it's okay
crystals and and healing properties and
having them around
again they're just something that i love
in my house saging
palo santo i'm very much into holistic
medicine and
all kinds of alternative therapies and
ways to feel good
self-care baths if i could bring a bath
here i would that's also another
essential
but i do have a huge collection of
crystals i love them very much and i
like to get them from different parts of
the world as well
when i travel so they not only remind me
of places i've been and
those experiences but they also look and
feel beautiful to have in the house
i keep crystals everywhere by the bed by
the spare bed
in my lounge room and my kitchen because
that's where i spend most of my time i
have a giant amethyst that i have at the
front door there's sort of certain
places where they
recommend that you put them in there's
places where you just feel like i want
to put this here and so i'm going to
sage is super important to me too it's
just one of those things where
i've traveled if i've had a bad day if
someone's had a bad day and they've come
to my house and they're going through a
breakup and they've got this energy when
they leave i'm like
i love you come back soon i'm like get
all that energy out of here
because it's good to get the energy out
of you and it's great to turn to a
friend but you don't want to be
stuck there kind of still thinking about
she should have dumped him earlier
and you should i should have told her to
dump him earlier so if you sage
you end up having less regrets about
those kinds of things it also smells
amazing
this is very exciting guys and you might
not have heard of these
a mask and i'm sure that sounds very
like okay great yeah face mask what you
couldn't think of a tenth essential
this is so essential right now this is
the most essential
aside from nurses and carers and
delivery people and all the people that
are working on the front lines but this
is what we can do this particular one
the pure mask is my favorite let me let
me just read it because i don't actually
know exactly
it's thin and light could have told you
that i am holding it it's a nano fiber
filter
i'm not exactly sure what that is but
it's not like nano fiber it sounds
pretty cool
but it is it has like three layers so
nothing comes in nothing really comes
out but it sits a little bit further
away from
your face like a lot of the other masks
like really kind of on there and when
you're talking it's like this is
happening and you're sweating and this
sort of sits a little
in front of your face so you're not
sweating you can talk and hear because
there's nothing worse than when
someone's talking and you go
so i can't understand you and they're
like hold on a second i'm like no not
that
rather not you then yeah i recommend
these these are my favorite
thanks for checking out my essentials i
hope that some of them were interesting
and uh maybe you'll try trough or rebel
or enjoy just having this conversation
good luck be care be care wow all right
this is going really well don't you
agree
i think we've really connected um next
time maybe we'll just play we're not
really strangers